tense and rocky relationship between the
two nations the fact that the two
presidents have talked and agreed on a
major
uh arms control agreement in their first
ever phone call well that's reassuring
and the five-year extension of the new
start treaty is indeed a bright spot in
other words pretty much
failing talks on arms control and
non-proliferation
so the new strategic arms reduction
treaty signed in 2010
now is the only thing that limits the
two world's largest nuclear arsenals and
is considered as
a insurance policy against a full-blown
arms race
russia was the first to offer the
extension of the treaty without
pre-conditions in early 2020 but the
trump administration
well showed lack of interest supposedly
because they were seeking a new deal
instead it will cover more
weapons but anyway the current treaty
was expiring on february 5th
which is a little bit a week from now
and this was an apparent
last-ditch attempt to save it and it
succeeded
so let's first have a listen to how the
kremlin
welcomed the news the president's
expressed satisfaction on reaching an
agreement on the extension of the
strategic arms reduction treaty
in the coming days all the necessary
procedures will be completed to ensure
the further functioning of this
important
international legal mechanism for the
mutual limitation of nuclear missile
arsenals
well the readout of the phone
conversation on the kremlin's webpage
described the conversation as a
business-like
and frank and you know the overall
emphasis was on mutual cooperation and
normalizing the relationship between the
two countries
and for example it is said that the two
leaders have discussed the possibility
of
joining forces and battling the pandemic
but
if you look at the white house webpage
and
the way the same conversation is
described there
you will see a different tone and angle
so let's have a listen
president biden made clear that the
united states will act firmly in defense
of its national
interests in response to actions by
russia that harm
us or our allies the two presidents
agreed to maintain transparent and
consistent communication
going forward so it seems like for
biden's administration
it is really important to stress that
the the newly elected american president
has confronted his russian counterpart
on various issues
and didn't just agreed uh to the
extension almost as if
you know stopping arms race from
escalating is not good enough
and you know what the american media
outlets immediately latched onto this
and they saw a dramatic change of tone
sort of look how donald trump spoke to
vladimir putin and how
joe biden just did although you know it
is worth mentioning that we didn't hear
the actual conversation
all we have are just the readouts and
there is a lot of diplomatic language
to it anyway when joe biden was asked
directly
how the phone call went he preferred to
laugh it off
mr president
[Music]
well so the important thing is that
there is a glimpse of hope that russia
and the united states won't fall into
the new round of
arms race but nevertheless uh it almost
feels like there is a certain ritual
that the american president has to
follow
in order to sell this at home